three two one go I'm with the five to
seven-year-olds are really having a baby
second hi there I'm Aria and last night
I spent an entire hour downloading and
trying to understand tik-tok it was very
long loud and confusing hour
so today I'm gonna spend some time with
a tick tock star I'm spending the day
with Arielle Martin otherwise known as
baby Arielle an 18 year old social media
phenom with a following of almost 30
million on tick tock alone and who was
even named by Time magazine as one of
the 25 most influential people on the
Internet
I know we're very met who might chew up
but we actually had a shot of us like
meeting oh yeah just pretend like you're
doing something thank you for coming to
my home this is my dad oh oh yeah nice
to meet nice to meet you yeah yeah Hosea
nice to meet you so I started on social
media about four years ago my brother
and I had been like playing around on
our phones a ton and we came across this
alcohol musically and I was like oh this
is awesome this is another way for me to
express myself it's like another
creative outlet that I can just use and
be like Here I am
and so I did that and it just like
people just really like the way it
videos and I would just make up every
single day and I just was gaining a
following I'm excited to beat you
because for me the world of social media
especially tik-tok and all these
evolutions have are very confusing to me
a thousand percent they're confusing to
me it's very hard to describe what
tic-tock is I think that's one of the
hardest things that I've found because
it is so broad and there's so much that
you're able to do on this one app you
are able to post absolutely any kind of
video that you have ever dreamt of on
tik-tok this is where I spend like a lot
of my time right here cuz I get my
makeup right here I put my iPod here
make my tic TOCs
I go to trim usually I found this like
the part of the song that I want to do
[Music]
you got that used it that one snippet
just for that yeah so now what I like to
play with a lot in tik-tok is like depth
perception um so you can come closer and
then it's just gonna go mm seems to go
mmm yeah what have a vibe do you want me
to give her that like like a predator
yeah three two one go
[Laughter]
tick tock and musically has always felt
like home to me
tick tock came at a point in my life
where I felt like disconnected a little
bit from the people at my school and the
people I was surrounding myself with
right now I think I'm not a period where
I'm very happy but I just I go through a
lot of periods where I feel very alone
and I don't have I feel like I don't
have anybody in my corner for some
reason even though I know I do like
logically but like here sometimes
doesn't feel like I look I have a lot of
people I don't know why I'm sad it just
I push a lot of people away for some
reason I should be happy with like me
myself like I have these people like
following me and around me but still
feeling alone with the struggles that
you go through and feeling alone with
your sadness and even the happiness
sometimes I think that's almost even
worse when you're happy and you have
just experienced something that you
wanted to experience your entire life
but feeling that like you have nobody to
share that with what's really great
about social media is that I'm able to
post online and say okay this is how I'm
feeling and other people are able to
respond and say hey I went through that
two months ago or I'm going through that
right now I understand you and I get it
and it's gonna be okay
no matter what you guys are always the
earth thank you for supporting me
constantly because we have to go through
it and that's what sucks yes it really
is truly the down times that make the
High Times exactly you need those low
times to say okay this is my happy so I
had to go through that period of
loneliness and I had to go through
period by myself to get to a point of
happiness where I am happy being alone
I'm happy with the people I've
surrounded myself with before leaving
Arielle I felt like my day wouldn't be
complete without posting my first ever
tik tok you definitely have to make your
first day time you know I want my my
presence on tik tok to be different okay
I want to make a statement a political
dynamic what political statement are you
thinking are you familiar with the
landmine crisis that's going around the
world right now should I know
so what effect do you want the first
there's tons of effects let's find a fun
one
not so fun topic quite wait no this has
to be a really good film sorry I just
wanted to be like really good so I'm
gonna start recording and when you stop
your sentence I'll stop recording and
then we didn't switch filters oh it's
fun yeah great okay so what's the first
thing you're gonna say I'm just gonna
say every year people continue to be
injured and killed by landmines that
around the world
ready yes set go
every year people continue to be maimed
or killed by land mines that have yet to
be disposed of I think is my name favor
tick tock understand that's gonna be a
very impactful fun time yes okay now you
just write a caption
please help now one two three I did it
65% we're going live you're making a
change
I'm making impact yes you know people
are gonna go on tick-tock they're gonna
see those people running around
screaming and they're gonna see this
every year people continue to be maimed
or killed by landmines that yet to be
disposed of this is a humanitarian
crisis the world is to be more aware of
yeah today I hope you'll go online to
learn more about this issue but we can
make a difference I'm so excited it's
gonna blow up
tick-tock er high-five I'm very proud of
you I'm very thank you so much for your
help
yes I mean you're welcome take stalkers
are good people I feel like for some
reason it's like okay like you're an
actor awesome you're singer awesome
beard influencer
I think that's sad because the people
who are doing tick tock like this they
it's all them it's them and a phone and
they're creating great content and
they're entertaining millions of people
from their bedroom and that's a really
awesome thing I have so much I want to
do
happiness is number one in whatever I'm
doing it's okay not to know who you are
but also it's okay to take the time for
yourself and dive into you and go on a
journey of figuring yourself out because
that's what I think we all need to spend
more time doing
you
[Music]